no if you have a PR if your problem is  someone else's Behavior you go to a  program for the solution because the  solution might be do nothing  the solution might be do not a damn  thing because we're so addicted to  taking an action that doesn't compute  does not compute so then I was like okay  I'm gonna go to this meeting so I can  figure out how to get her so  but yes The Lies We Tell ourselves and  the delusions and look I had a ton of  proof that I was a super high function  as a perfectionist as a micromanager and  as a martyr which makes it harder  because the world is smiling upon you  and you're being wildly rewarded for  these unhealthy Behavior patterns that  you're blindly unaware at some point are  really going to derail you at best and  might actually kill you sometimes we're  hurting people in ourselves and we don't  even know it